a string or string literal it's a series
of zero or more characters enclosed in
single or double quotes
there is the string of my name which is
bow if you need a quote character in
your string you can escape a quote from
considering it as an end of a string
quote by placing a backslash in front of
the quote so here let me show you that
so here I made a string and it's he said
hi so it that's gonna look like this he
said hi when you put a backslash in from
the quote character the program knows
that you're not trying to end the string
you're just trying to use the quote
character in the string a string values
in JavaScript may be written with single
or double quotes so so long as you start
and end with the same type of quote you
don't have to escape a quote character
as long as it is a different type of
quote character than we're surrounding
your string so what you could do you can
make this sentence one again you can not
escape these quote characters and you
can put a single quote at the end and at
the beginning okay there are also other
characters you need to escape which
means to put a backslash in front in
order to use them as a string so they
have backslash single quote yes I do the
single quote here's how you do the
double quote whenever you want to
backslash in a string you just do two
backslashes the first backslash is the
escape character you can also put in a
new line a character turn on a tab a
backspace and a form feed you can
concatenate or put two strings together
with the plus operator so here it's
going to put two things together it's
going to look like this and it's
basically just going to be one string
that has my name foe Carnes and watch
out for spaces concatenation does not
add spaces between concatenate strings
so you have to add them yourself that's
why I have the space after the word bow
you
also concatenate strings and variables
so that would just be my name is Bo
Carnes let's do my name is going to add
the full name which is it's variable up
here another way to concatenate strings
is uses is using the plus equals
operator like this so the plus equals
operator means that you are going to
start with this variable and then add
this to the end of the variable it
really means full name equals full name
plus is my name so the full name
variable is now going to be so that's
what the full name variable is going to
be now
the final thing I want to tell you about
strings is that in JavaScript string
values are immutable which means they
cannot be altered once created now you
can assign a variable to a new string
but you can't actually change the
original string we have sentence twice
you so you can assign sentence to a new
string but you can't actually change the
original string like arrays you can
change an element in the array but you
can't change a character in the string
after you create it thanks for watching
my name is beau Carnes don't forget to
subscribe and remember use your code for
good